so keeping with the fact that we need
stories and the crave stories it's part
of the human experience yeah how does
someone tell a great one okay how does
someone engaged well that's the 64
million good question right how do you
tell great story well you have to know
okay so you talk about what stories do
to us so because we because they're part
of us and I was we evolved with stories
and so stories are part of us we our
brains have evolved to work hard what
I've heard people say there are we
hardwired for stories in other words we
our brain is evolved to appreciate
stories in a certain way to do what it's
supposed to do so I like to use the
example of a sugar coated pill you know
like a kind of things that you give to a
dog and you need the dog leans into
medicine but the only way the dog is
gonna eat the pill is if it's rats or on
the base but sugar right like to make it
really appealing stories are that
there's sugar quit bill so at the core
of a story is the the meaning the
purpose of what it supposed to do which
is to teach us a specific lesson right
and everything else is the coding to
make it entertaining in other words so
the you know the comedy the horror the
suspend although all these emotions that
we talked about that we love that we pay
money to see are the sugar to make it
entertaining so in order to tell a good
one so you have to know how to make it
entertaining that's part of it but you
also can't miss that kernel which is the
demeaning why why that story what's it's
what what are you trying to say with
that story what's the message you trying
to say so you have to know that because
stories are lessons for us and the only
way we could relate in the only way we
could absorb that message is to see
someone experiencing what we're supposed
to learn so there's a thing called
mirror neurons which I don't know if
you've heard basically our brains kind
of don't know the difference between
imagination and reality so this is
something that was discovered by Italian
scientists they were studying monkeys
and trying to figure out what happens in
their brain
when they do things so they were they
were they were studying a monkey
grabbing a banana and they saw what part
of their brains lit up okay and then
they saw the brain of a monkey watching
another monkey grab a banana and they
saw that it was the same exact firing
patterns in other words the same part of
their brain of the monkey seeing the
monkey grab a banana was the same as if
the monkey was grabbing the banana so
it's called mirror neurons there's
something we have to and the lesson of
that is that when we watch something we
watch a character in the screen going
through something our brain is thinking
that we're doing it okay so if you're if
you see a couple kissing the same parts
of the brain will light up as you
kissing someone you may not actually
feel it but it's the same part of the
brain so you're experiencing what's
going on in the screen and if a
character is struggling to accomplish
something you're by default you're
watching this and so in a subconscious
level you are learning what the
character is learning so for me great
stories are about teaching us how to
live and the way to do that is by
showing a character who changes who
transforms and that transformation
because change is so difficult for us in
real life we need to see a character
accomplishing that change to see how
they did it and that's how we learn so
that's kind of a quick way of saying how
to tell a good story which is like show
a character who struggles to achieve a
certain goal and who transforms as a
result of that and has a great
resolution in and all that surrounded by
you know dramatic techniques that keep
us engaged because that's very important
that's another thing about that was
talking about story is that stories were
designed to feel good because it's the
way for us to pay attention to in other
words you need to make the brain pay
attention to your story in order to get
the lesson out of it and all all the
stuff about you know entertainment
that's the paying
- in other words when you show for
example you create suspense you know in
a thriller right your brain is doing
something that makes you pay attention
that's how we evolved to do that so you
know dopamine there's oxytocin which is
the empathy drug nib that you're you
know mothers get that when they're
babies we get that when we hug someone
so oxytocin is a is this what's called
the social or the bonding hormone
because we're social animals and so when
you see a character and you create a
character that you care about so there's
actual techniques dramatic techniques
you can use to make us care for a
character then oxytocin is going through
your brain and you bond with that
character you care about that character
that's what keeps you engaged in the
story and you paying attention
you're not disengage so that's how you
tell a good story and if you don't know
this if you don't know how to make us
care about the character which I see
that all the time right you read scripts
that don't work you see movies that
don't work because we don't care about
the character so that already you failed
if you don't care about the character I
don't care how many bombs or set pieces
or thrilling twists you have we just
don't care about a character you're just
not gonna get the story you disengaged
your board so caring about the character
is step number one step number two is
keeping us engaged through again
dramatic techniques and hopefully you
have a purpose your story a meaning to
your story so there's a you know when
you finish the story is finish and you
think about you go home I get it and
that's how you appreciate it that makes
the story good I think
you